wir bewegen uns sind eine neue gelände
kammer des wahnsinns der kirchen war
wichtig geschichte von unserem kollegen
habe ich paul ronzheimer der momentan in
kabul die taliban regierung zur
zivilisierung versucht haben wir gelesen
dass es eine deutsche firma gibt die
eine art joint venture ritz macht mit
einem mit den taliban dass die trauben
im rahmen ihres ersten exportprodukt
nach dem islamismus haben sie jetzt ein
zweites exportprodukt entdeckt das ist
das gar navis und in deutschland hat er
die regierung gesagt sie gedenke das
dollar bis zu legalisieren jetzt haben
also diese taliban und die deutschen
beschlossen deutschland habe mit
cannabis zu beliefern wenn das wenn das
damals legalisiert wird und hierzu habe
ich eigentlich folgendes zu sagen was
jetzt von den taliban also mir ist
ehrlich gesagt lieber wenn die taliban
statt islamismus oder kalaschnikows wenn
sie gar bis zu exportieren das finde ich
besser das ist ein zivilisatorischer
fortschritt sie könnten ja auch opium
und betrogen exportieren das ist
eigentlich positiv aber wovor ich
wirklich unbedingt wahren möchte er
liebe freunde in deutschland
was auf keinen fall dürfte hier das
cannabis legalisieren also dauert es ein
bisschen gegen das was sie vorhin gesagt
haben ich wünsche ich will kein begriff
des deutschland wir brauchen ein
deutschland das in den herausforderungen
der gegenwart mit absolut wachen geist
sagt man muss nicht gleich abstinent
sein wien ag herbert aber mit maß aber
ich finde ich mir vorstelle dass jetzt
schon alles läuft auf diesem planeten
und dann haben wir noch ein begriff des
deutschland also dann muss ich sogar ich
aus chronischen optimise sagen dann bin
ich verliere ich meine zuversicht außer
deutschland musste ghana bis mäßig
nüchtern bleiben ich dachte deutschland
ist schon total bekifft aber
ich habe hier würde ich gerne frau dr
rubin sie als ärztin wie schädlich ist
denn auch also kann aber es wird ja auch
oft leicht gerät ein gesellschaft wie
ist es wie es ihre einschätzung zur
legalisierung von cannabis ich mal die
haben jetzt in die ärztin am platz
sitzen wie es ihr eigentlich denkt man
muss ja wissen cannabis hat ja zwei
wirkstoffen der eine hat diese
berauschende und diese beruhigende
wirkung und das andere ist das cbd was
wir in der medizin verwenden können weil
es nämlich entzündungshemmend und
schmerzlindernd und ich glaube schon
dass es ein sinnvolles medikament ist
was gerade einzug erhält ja was für
bestimmte patientengruppen gerade noch
geht aber wo sicherlich weiter werden
wird das mit dem kiffen ja also ich muss
sagen ich habe den eindruck dass ganz
viele leute kiffen ist einfach so und
ich nicht würde der komischen blick
kommt weil ich das nicht vertrage aber
nein ich finde irgendwie ich weiß nicht
so genau ob man sich darunter sollten
könnte man im laden kaufen also das will
die am player die will ja die
legalisierung von cannabis ist heidi
nach hause jähriger könnte den laden
gehen und sich kann aber dass ich euch
was sagen dass ganz wichtig meine idee
nicht jetzt den sie wissen doch viel
besser bescheid aber ich kann das meiner
lebenserfahrung sprechen ich war früher
intensiv musiker aber schlagzeug
gespielt jazzbands blues alles das ganze
programm und ich konnte das beobachte
meine kollegin im alter von 14 15 jahren
glauben da angefangen zu kiffen manche
haben daraus dann ein hobby gemacht
einige musiker geworden anders in
professionelle hilfe geworden und da
muss ich aber sagen wenn ich jetzt diese
käfer karrieren anschauen das kommt dass
das ist irgendwie schädlich also ich
würde auch sagen dass alkohol ist eine
ganz heimtückische droge aber das kiffen
das wird unterschätzt und da ich glaube
dass das führt zu so einen ort was ist
das ein gesellschaftliches hänger
syndrom er hast du das gefühl du bist im
flow das leben ist eine hängematte rot
rot grün regiert das kommt alles gut
hätte gd sie aber irgendwann am ende
muss nach einer dass rot-rot
ich finde dieses cannabis dieses system
das video unterschätzt ja stimmt das
stimmt auch das macht vereinigen was mit
dem gehirn und was ganz ganz
dramatisches sondern sieht man eben
leider auch wieder bei jugendlichen
ziemlich genau und depressionen class
heißt das verändert unsere hirnstruktur
so dass wir dann einfach emotional ab
krachen und dann hat man ja genau das
gegenteil erreicht von dem was man
eigentlich will und dafür bin ich immer
dafür zu sagen wir brauchen eigentlich
zu verbieten wir müssen über die risiken
aufklären ja und wenn ich weiß was eine
zigarette mit mehr macht und ich noch
nicht süchtig bin kann ich mir überlegen
alkohol wir haben und wir haben so viele
alkoholabhängige ich weiß es nicht genau
die zeit ist glaube ich 5 millionen oder
so das ist massiv ja wir haben ein
problem und genauso mit dem cannabis die
ganzen psychischen folgen natürlich dass
darüber muss man reden die frage ist
bloß grundsätzlich wie verfahren damit
dem einen das eine burka verbieten das
andere war marie legalisieren was
wussten da der sinn der ganzen sache
also eigentlich müsste man doch sagen
risikoaufklärung und alles was wir
verbieten gibt es sowieso nur dann auf
dem schwarzen aber nicht genauso ich
habe in den usa gelebt und dort ist
cannabis legal also zumindest in
kalifornien und ist das merkt man naja
ist wenn ich die politik und ja muss ich
sagen das ist
die kalifornier live aber die deutschen
wenn ich das einfach so mal wahrnehmen
und beurteilen dürfte sind bekiffter wie
sich schon sagen es braucht kein mensch
aber die deutschen sind
umtriebiger als die california weil es
vielleicht hier einfach etwas besonderes
ist und jeder weiß ist super leicht zu
besorgen ich lebe in bremen da läuft man
einmal durch sogenannte viertel man
kriegt es zehn mal angeboten auf 10
metern jedes kind kann sich das besorgen
wenn es das möchte und vielleicht macht
es gerade den reiz aus das ist verboten
ist ich meine überhaupt nicht dass es
legal werden sollte um gottes willen
aber auf jeden fall habe ich beobachtet
in den usa das ist auf gar keinen fall
gängiger ist also ich möchte wieder
sprechen einfach nur das widerspreche
electric sozusagen noch zu haben
jetzt üben ich bin selbstverständlich
dafür dass das cannabis legal ist wenn
dadurch dass es illegal ist vor allem
ein millionengeschäft für die arabischen
clans die sich hier die sich in
einen markt geschaffen haben in
kalifornien gibt es leben die schon aus
wie apple stores da kannst du das ändern
so dass kaum ein ist natürlich ganz
nicht nochmal auf die medizinische eben
nicht hat dass auch meine kinder gesagt
jetzt machen was ihr wollt ich bitte
euch nur bis ihr einen mehr waren auf
seiten ein bisher 21 bisher 21 seid
bitte nicht weil das gehirn wie sie
schon sagen das gehirn wird dadurch
beeinflusst und es ist eines dieser
themen die der tatsächlich so komplex
sind dass sie dass sie endlich in
wenigen minuten behandelt werden können
eines der großen großen problemen der
klassischen drogenpolitik des war on
drugs wieder george hw bush erklärt hat
war dass es vor allem ein
milliardengeschäft für die mafia ist
wenn sie durch berlin gehen und lange
dunkle mercedes mit verdunkelten
scheiben sehen können sie davon ausgehen
dass am schwarzmarkt verdientes geld ist
das und das geld ist natürlich ist ideal
für die ein monopol zu haben das heißt
das ist ein richtiges problem wenn sie
das kontrolliert wenn sie das
kontrolliert abgeben und und sie
sicherstellen dass dann das nur
erwachsene wenn ich als erwachsener
entscheide ich möchte marihuana rauchen
dann ist das meine entscheidung ich
glaube dass die grünen sich da keinen
gefallen tun dass sie dass sie dass sich
das dass sie das fordern denn wir reden
jetzt alle von der entlastung des
gesundheitssystems und 6 milliarden und
das problem wird sein dass natürlich wir
dass wir natürlich unsere
psychiatrischen anstalten ausbauen
müssen denn er selbstständig wird es zu
größeren psychosen also ja dahinter das
wird sich so ja ich finde das irgendwie
finde das argument wirklich überzeugen
dass die liberale sichtweise auf die
drogen und irgendwo mein hirn kann das
mit nachvollziehen da steht natürlich
mit diesen industrien aber wenn ich ganz
ehrlich mir ein hohler muss ich sagen
gefühlsmäßig überzeugt mich das argument
nicht und ich irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl also bei auch gefühlsmäßig man
könnte sagen vorurteilsbehaftet aus
irgendwelchen instinktiven regungen
heraus würde ich zurückschrecken mit dem
argument müsste man zum beispiel auch
das kokain und alle harten drogen
legalisiert das stimmt und würde der
drogenmafia eigentlich das ganze
geschäft wegnehmen mexiko könnte
vielleicht zu einem blühenden land
werden trotzdem du dich zögern hier
einfach die dämme zu öffnen aber du
vielleicht irre ich nicht vielleicht
hast du dich vielleicht muss man das
liberalisieren ich will es trotzdem
nicht machen es gibt manchmal im leben
entscheidungen macht man hat nämlich die
wahl zwischen richtig und falsch und
inzwischen du falsch und weniger falsch
und das ist das ist in meinem leben
möchte system einbringen alexander zu
die ja ich bin ja es ist ja eine ganz
neue rolle normalerweise wir immer einer
meinung aber ich finde ganz schlimm an
der legalisierung von cannabis ich
verstehe dein argument mit der ist in
die drogenszene auch ein bisschen ja
nicht mehr so ist wie sie jetzt ist aber
wenn es legal wäre würden glaube ich
viel mehr 18-jährige doch ist einfach
mal ausprobieren und noch mal und noch
mal machen ist ja legal ist ja wie
zigaretten und alkohol und eine
stabilisierung aber noch nichts doch
auch oder ich habe in holland studiert
in maastricht er sagen ich habe ihn
geliebt bei mir haben aber etliche
gekifft ich fand ich habe genau die
kiefer persönlichkeit kennengelernt die
regie angesprochen hat diejenigen
übrigens die gekifft haben ihr studium
nicht zu ende gebracht in der
regelstudienzeit wie ich und die anderen
wenig gekauft haben ich habe genau das
was du über ein polizist alena so ging
es mir ein maß ich habe da ist ein paar
versprochen ich niemals sich dafür und
habe und niemals geholfen die gemacht
niemals nein ich schwöre aber wegen
einem anderen grund ich hatte das
erlebnis wie du mit dem alkohol ich habe
da an einem abend sah sich da und die
leute waren so träge und haben so
rumgehangen und dieses gar nicht so
schlimm und es hat mich so was war deine
mögliche entscheidung ich bin ich bleibe
meiner linie treu dass derartig
enttabuisierung ist nicht so schlimm das
ist auch eine frage die wir
gesellschaftlich damit umgehen wenn die
grünen das heroisieren und sagen und
sagen das ist so was toll ist und so
weiter ich würde selbstverständlich
immer mehr verwarnen und ich würde sagen
das ist gerade für junge leute ihr macht
euer gehirn kaputt und es sind gibt der
rauch lang sie hat schon gebremst daher
weist das übrigens auch das interessant
jetzt komme ich als drogenexperte der
herr
wir müssen das nächste mal
[Gelächter]
verbrachte ich hab' ich hab ich ja und
nein aber es ist